so we're here in the archives of the
Royal Society in London the UK Academy
of Sciences and it's full of the most
wonderful things the first sample of
polythene sampled from Newton's apple
tree the silver guilds insignia of the
Royal Society the British Standard Pound
model boats there's even a Sputnik up
there as well of course the documents
but that's not what I want to show you
come over here there's something that's
chemically more interesting so look at
these these are the fire safety system
so it's a mixture of nitrogen argon and
co2 you can see they haven't given the
right symbol for argon it should have a
little R a lowercase R not a big one the
reason for this is because it's heavy
gases and it displaces the oxygen from
the room and so the whole place fills up
with gas which will not support
combustion so even if the rest of the
building is burning you can't have a
fire in here because there's no oxygen
and the air being lighter will just be
wafted out through the ventilation
system and you'll be left with the room
absolutely full of gas that will not
support combustion because these things
are so historic it would be a tragedy if
they were damaged by fire and we do have
fire alarms here I've last week I was
here in late at night we all trooped out
because the fire alarm malfunction but
just for a small fire alarm this thing
doesn't trigger it will only trigger if
there is a big fire in here these are
really big cylinders they're at 300
atmospheres which is a higher pressure
than when normally uses in cylinders
normally there are only 200 atmospheres
and there's a system here that will
distribute it around the room and if
this goes off and you're in here you
would have to run really hard because it
would fill up with co2
I think the reason that it's mixed with
nitrogen and argon is to make sure that
it's a gas at room temperature and it's
quite cold in here which is why I'm
wearing this jacket and so because if
you used ordinary co2 which would be a
liquid in these cylinders if it expanded
it would come out as dry ice and the
place would be full of dry ice and the
atmosphere wouldn't be replaced quickly
enough they'd use such a high pressure
so that they can get more gas into a
smaller volume because if the whole
place was full of gas cylinders where
would you put the treasures so 300 bar
is a good compromise between the size of
the cylinder and the amount of gas you
can put in because if you have to higher
pressure the metal gets thicker and
thicker and you'd never be able to get
the cylinder down the stairs or in the
lift here because it would be so heavy
there you go look at that all this stuff
here and we're filming the cylinders